so thanks very much to Karen and David
for inviting me I met them a couple of
years ago at - one of the story
conferences when they were interviewing
a number of the speakers and they really
had good questions and I so enjoyed
visiting with them and then we did
another one when my romantic comedy book
came out and once again you know how hmm
you know how sometimes you see
interviews and you think what are you
thinking why did you ask that but not
the case with them they always ask
wonderful wonderful questions and get
right to what is so helpful for those of
us who are creating content so this
evenings topic is mythic challenges
create stories that change the world so
I want to know a little bit more about
you first so that I can hopefully make
some of the commentary more relevant to
what you're doing so let's just go with
how many of you are writers okay great
producers directors actors now actors or
is nobody admitting it I see I see
actually I taught a group of actors last
week who were here from Denmark to learn
about Hollywood showbiz acting etc and
that was quite interesting how many of
you have a specific cause that you are
behind with some kind of involvement
whether it's equality social justice
ecology anybody got a favorite okay all
right great thank you Malaysia
ain't much money today and I presume
that most of us are here tonight because
of two to three things we realize we're
in a big ol mess here on this planet and
we want to do something about it and
make positive changes and there's an
interest in mythology and the classic
tools of storytelling and how can we put
all those together brief little history
about mythic challenges back in 2011 I
was at a conference about the future of
story and the global challenges that the
world is facing and there's an
organization called the Millennium
Project and I believe it's referenced a
number of places in the handout and they
along with the United Nations identified
15 global challenges that we all face
now and it one of the pages of the
handouts there is a list of those 15 and
when you go to their website you'll find
links to all kinds of research and
organizations who are dealing
specifically with those now for
storytellers you know the bad news is
we've got a lot of problems the good
news is there's a wide range of problems
one of them is international organized
crime so if you're writing a crime or
espionage thriller that's you could plug
right in there it's a global challenge
it's a big problem
the rich-poor gap because everybody
bought their Mega Millions ticket talk
about your rich-poor gap let's make
another one percenter okay and certainly
social justice and women's rights
education going from MMD's murderous
military dictatorships or countries
ruled by demagogues into democracies
oh there's such a wide range of these
challenges so some colleagues and I were
at this conference about it
here in LA and my co-founder partner
said hey I've got an idea and so we've
just huddled a little bit and then he
stood up and he said we've decided to
form an organization that helps people
who want to address the challenges do it
with storytelling yeah everybody thought
that's a great idea
our pilot project was at a school a high
school in Reseda and they had a very
good film communications
department and they had a sister school
at a couple of sister schools in
Afghanistan so we designed the class
like what you're going to get tonight
but it was no real hands-on with the
kids because they were just coming into
learning about some of these concepts
and each of them chose one of the
challenges and then one of the mythic
themes to follow and they learned about
the five are capaz or your clergy
scientist magician and lover in order to
put their characters in one of those
categories or another and then how to
use symbolism to tell your stories so
they worked together with their fellow
students in Afghanistan through the
State Department and you know Facebook
videos etc and they came up with some
really really good programs
one of them's only two minutes another
one I think is about eighteen minutes
and these projects that the kids did
we're out there winning awards so we saw
that it really worked even with young
people especially with young people
because you know they have a vested
interest in improving the future so you
can go to our website and go to the
videos section and see some of theirs in
fact I would urge you just for a laugh
and to see how effective this can be
watch the one about water it's not a
game or water it's not a contest it's
only two minutes long it's really cute
and there are no words spoken in it but
it gets the idea across
point being you can use these tools and
you can address these problems in any
style you want to in any genre you want
to to get across your point so how many
of you have a an interest in mythology
that before I you're here okay
has anybody got a particular favorite
realm of myth like the greco-roman or
the Polynesian or anything in particular
or is it more generic interest okay
that's good because what you find when
you get into comparative mythology is
that let me back up and say what are
myths myths are not just the dusty old
stories of the Greeks and Romans nor are
myths other people's religion nor as a
grade schooler once said a myth is a
female moth you know myths are the
stories that we tell ourselves to
explain the world around us and within
us that's it the stories we tell
ourselves to explain the world around us
and the world within us and as a side
note of both of those to justify the
worlds that we have created and one of
the examples I use for that is the
Aeneid this epic poem of it a Trojan
Prince leaving the burning ruins of Troy
after they were defeated by the Greeks
making his way across the Mediterranean
having all sorts of adventures including
a very tragic love affair with the queen
of Carthage and eventually he gets to
realm because that's his destiny
according to the gods and he founds
realm well that's a neat story it was
commissioned by the Emperor Augustus and
Augustus said to the poet Virgil
we need a foundation myth we need to
justify our existence and we want to be
one up on the Greeks so Virgil
this wonderful wonderful poem and it's
called the undead and it's this fabulous
journey with all kinds of adventures and
monsters and trips to the underworld and
really interesting stuff very heroic
and you know part of the point was yeah
you Greeks thought you'd put us down at
Troy but we're back and we're right next
door and we're gonna be better than you
and you know see more in history so the
foundation myths are important the
journey myths are important
the self-discovery myths one of the ones
we'll talk about as a mythic theme
tonight is the wake-up call now let me
also say as we go into this we need
heroes we absolutely need more heroes
today and I'm using gender-neutral hero
keep in mind that by definition a hero
is someone who stands up above the rest
of the crowd and who says whoa this is
not working let's do something about it
and then leads a movement for change but
think about this in just your symbolism
of them stepping up the hero rises above
the crowd this can also be dangerous
because then you're a target you know
see more at the assassinations of people
trying to make change and the
establishment doesn't like it whether
it's you know once again ancient Rome
and the cracky brothers who've been
likened to the Kennedy brothers who were
assassinated for much the same reason so
we find a lot of echoes in history and
myth to what's going on today how many
of you have any hope that we can change
any of these problems that we're facing
yeah
once again self-selected audience that's
why you're here all right and we know we
can I want to plant a seed in your minds
we've seen a lot of devolution lately
there's just been
way more than I think we need of
dystopian films post-apocalyptic stories
it's like enough of the bleak already
you occasionally you want to see those I
mean it's it can be entertaining you
know Ferry Road okay 30 minutes of story
two hours worth of great visual
adventure right okay and we like these
things but there's been so much of that
it seems to permeate the consciousness
and some people say brings about a sense
of hopelessness but sometimes you have
to explore the darkness in order to
change it and rise above it so it's not
you know totally useless what's what's
going on there with the the devolution
stories get there mainly cautionary
tales like the Greek tragedies it tells
you what not to do because this is how
it can go horribly horribly wrong then
you have revolution and if any of you've
studied history or you just watch the
news or you've read anything at all you
see that revolutions occur over and over
and over again throughout history and in
almost every place on the planet the
problem with the revolution is your only
revolving it's like a pig on a spit
you've been cooking the belly you have a
revolution now you're cooking the back
well guess what it's going to keep
turning counter revolutions and see more
about the caravan of people coming up
from Central America some say part of
the reason for that although there's
certainly plenty of homegrown problems
but part of it was because they got
caught into the revolution counter
revolutions of the 80s and 90s that
America was part of ok so it's sort of
like I cynically say it's kind of like
well it's the Empire Strikes Back you
know you go out there and colonize what
do you think is going to happen
eventually and you see this over and
over in history and the fall of Empires
so revolutions not necessarily a great
idea for lasting change evolution that's
where we want to go so we want to be
moving instead of in a cyclic fashion we
want to be moving up we want to get once
again that heroic point of view and this
is what I would urge all of you to do as
writers even if you're writing about
somebody that doesn't make it at least
show us what it should look like okay so
we need heroes I'm hoping that you're
going to be writing them for us and I
would suggest that you do take a look at
the these 15 global challenges and maybe
you're already writing a story that
specifically addresses one of these or
maybe you can work it in as a subplot or
you maybe could even just have one
character come in there's a party going
on and everybody's doing party stuff and
then somebody comes in and and they're
all yeah and somebody says well what are
you so down about and they can give a
little speech and you've placed that in
your story and just the fact of making
us all more aware is going to help wake
more people up and we need that we need
that in order to create stories that
change the world but it doesn't have to
be the whole story about that particular
problem so anywhere along that spectrum
of a mention to that's what the story's
about so let's talk about three things
here as far as mythic tools the main
mythic tools
as I see it our mythic themes and
archetypes
and symbols and this is what you'll find
working throughout all the best stories
is that they will have a specific theme
and what makes it a mythic theme it's a
theme that keeps being told over and
over and over again once again with
comparative mythology you find the same
stories showing up whether it's in New
Zealand with the Maori or it's in
northwest America or Korea or the
Teutonic myths Egyptian etc we keep
telling the same stories because the
human experience is rather similar good
news for you is it's pretty global so
just by tapping into these mythic themes
you're going to be reaching something
very deep within all of us as humans and
that's the great news for storytellers
is that oh and there's a an article and
I believe it's it's in my latest
newsletter and maybe the one before but
that your brain on story there's a whole
lot of neuroscience going on that shows
us how story works and how it affects
the brain also in case you didn't
already know that you're different from
other people the creative brain is
physiologically different from the
brains of muggles so you know you can
sit up a little straighter know that
you've got a great brain and you really
are different so we just want to be
using it for the best possible results
so let's take a look first then at
mythic themes and then we'll look at are
capacitive archetypes and then we'll
take a look at symbols now we'll be
doing a Q&A session at the end but if
anywhere along here if I say something
that you don't quite get
I haven't said it clearly enough or
defined it well enough please raise your
hand and and make sure that I do that
and then we'll try to keep the questions
for the end so that we can keep moving
through but I want to be sure that
everybody understands and sometimes you
know it's just the way you make a
statement that isn't quite clear so all
right so mythic themes and there are
dozens of them as you can see they're in
your handout and they range from the
very personal my life isn't going well I
need to make some changes what am I
going to do the wake-up call I really
want to be in love I want the search for
the soulmate we got to get out of this
place take the search for the promised
land and many many many more
now when you just on your own go through
this I've listed a number of stories
both in myth and in media that you can
then follow up and add your own and
start this collection if you start
thinking this way what I would like for
us all to be better at is recognizing
patterns and that's what storytellers do
too is they work with patterns if we've
become more conscious of it then we
become better storytellers so by looking
this over and reading is that oh yeah
I've seen that one yeah I see that one
okay and maybe see again a couple of the
films in each of these categories and
you will begin to recognize the patterns
and then you'll probably find that you
personally have an affinity for a couple
of them over the others and say yeah
that's the kind of story I want to tell
so when we're talking about appropriate
themes for these 15 global challenges
well once again just about any theme can
include it but a couple of the ones that
are quite appropriate are these
the don't-ask don't-tell or as I've
taken to calling it now - it's the
secret identity now
hiding
hiding in plain sight hiding under cover
of camouflage my nose or whatever but
it's one of my army friends who is in
intelligence used to say oh I'm don't
mind me I'm just a rat in the pipes so
they don't even notice I'm there but I'm
there
well okay tell me more well I can't okay
but the secret identity so you've got
someone who can infiltrate think about
the whistleblowers or people who are
investigative journalists you know we
used to have that back in the olden days
actual journalists actually went out and
investigated and did exposes and it was
real news and fact-checked quite a
concept isn't it so the secret identity
there's some wonderful stories about
this and part of the the arc of the
story is going from somebody going in
undercover and then how they get
discovered or not and how they discover
what they need to know and the dangers
that face them like in any heroic action
it's heroic because there is resistance
one of the laws of physics and
metaphysics is form resists change it's
one of Newton's three laws a body at
rest tends to stay at rest a body in
motion tends to stay in motion so you're
always going to be meeting resistance
and you'll hear this over and over again
in story workshops you'll read it in the
books you observe it in what you're
writing and in your own life in order to
have drama I have to have conflict and
the conflict can come from the
environment from a specific antagonist
group of antagonists your society your
culture your own foibles but once again
the the hero is the person who fights
against that and rise
above it even if just for a glimpse but
often for you know a longer time and
really makes things happen so the Don't
Ask Don't Tell now one of my favorites
and if you haven't seen it it's so fun
Galaxy Quest yeah isn't it great it's a
group of actors a spoof on the Star Trek
series right and a group of actors get
taken up to space by a group of aliens
who think that it's real they think the
show is real and that the captain is a
real captain and the ship's a real ship
and they've built they've built the ship
on their own from there like fanboys
right the aliens and they've they've
built the entire ship the actors realize
they have to pretend to be their
characters in order to accomplish the
goals that have been thrust upon them so
it's a real fun story on that theme with
some very poignant moments and times and
a lot of good character development the
characters arc and change it's it's
really good very well-written you might
take a look at that and very
entertaining and there's lots of great
lines from it too yes
never give up never surrender yeah and
also there are a lot of love stories
there under the Don't Ask Don't Tell so
another good one and this I think is is
probably the iconic mythic theme is
stealing fire from heaven prometheus was
one of the old gods one of the old Greek
gods here's the thing that happens over
and over again in mythology - you have
the war in heaven where one group of
gods takes over they battle with and
take over from the other one you know
see more at countries empires cultures
yeah galaxies universes this is what
happens in stealing fire from heaven
Prometheus who is one of the old gods
he's one of the Titans
he looks down
sees humans and we're stumbling around
and you know learning things and but
it's kind of bleak and it's kind of cold
if you're not in the tropics and when
the Sun Goes Down so do you because it's
dark and he says you know what these
people need fire just think what they
could do with fire well the problem with
that is you're not supposed to take
things from heaven and give it to the
Earthlings is like the prime directive
and Star Trek right don't mess with
their progress let them discover it on
their own but Prometheus has a soft
heart he's very idealistic and he wants
to help these people he wants to help
them improve their lives that that's a
very heroic stance but he's not supposed
to he knows it could be a problem if
it's discovered but he chooses to do it
anyway and this is one of those turning
points in your story where he's reminded
that that's against the law in this
pantheon you're not supposed to do that
and he does it anyway he realizes that
he may suffer because of what he's going
to do but he does it anyway also a thing
that your Prometheus type hero can run
up against is some of the people you're
trying to help don't want your help or
they don't trust you you know like the
old phrase from the 60s 70s movie
limousine liberal like oh you rich
people are gonna come down here to our
neighborhood and help us out oh well
thank you very much we don't need you so
there's often resistance from the group
that you're going in to help they don't
trust you you're coming in from the
outside what's your real agenda what are
you really trying to get here so even
more opposition even more drama and
conflict for your character so
Prometheus does it anyway steals the
fire brings it down to humans and voila
you've got light at night
you've got barbecue
you've got you can you know burn fields
burn forests and plant fields and all
the things that fire brings us it's
great for humans well this does not go
unnoticed and so the gods go prometheus
come here and say you knew what you were
doing you knew there was going to be
yeah yeah I know but they really needed
it they and look how well they're doing
and then you can have somebody say we
didn't want them to do well we're trying
to keep them enslaved what were you
thinking or something to that effect and
here again particularly if you've got
whistleblower situations going on so
Prometheus punishment was chained to a
rock in the Caucasus big ol Rocky
Mountains there the eastern end of the
Mediterranean and every day an eagle
would come down and peck out his liver
and then every night it would grow back
and the next day the eagle would come
back again and peck out his liver again
daily recurring endless eternal pain and
hopelessness really tragic so there are
a few versions of this myth where
Prometheus gets Unchained Hercules comes
and saves him and there are some poems
and stories written about that even in
more modern times
so check out Prometheus Unbound if
you're working on that kind of a story
and sometimes depending on the point you
want to make let's just make this divide
you've got drama and you've got drama
that has a happy ending and drama that
has a tragic ending hey the Greek
tragedies once again they're cautionary
tales so just be sure if you're doing a
cost
Neri tail and it doesn't end well for
your hero and what they're trying to do
at least show us what victory would have
looked like we need to know what they
lost it's like you know Moses standing
and looking over into the Promised Land
but he can't go there or Kevin Costner
on the sailboat in Waterworld knowing
that he's not going to go and land and
be on land and it's really kind of hard
to compare Kevin Costner in Waterworld
to Moses and you know but still and that
search for the Promised Land thing you
want to show us what victory would look
like so we're really sad when it doesn't
happen and how this can work for your
creature stories that change the world
then people in your audience may go okay
I see why that didn't work I'm going to
try it I'm gonna do it differently I
know what not to do it's probably a
whole lot of other things that could go
wrong - but I'm inspired to pick up that
baton to carry on that mission so even a
tragedy can inspire other people to move
forward so you're stealing fire from
heaven now one of the films that the
kids the high school kids did they took
the stealing fire from heaven themed and
as one of the kids said when I was
talking like this today he goes mister
that's like Robin Hood right yeah that's
the Robin Hood story steal from the rich
the gods give to the poor the humans
whether it's learning you know the
teacher comes in and helps kids learn
and education is one of the challenges
okay like Dead Poets Society stealing
fire from heaven is the Robin Hood story
and they made a really effective and
compelling drama about that so once
again do check out their video
if you have a chance so another one is
the wake-up call you find this in a lot
of stories it's it's something that
presumably we all do at various points
in our lives anyway so it's more of a
psychological story theme because I mean
just think about if any of you have kids
or grandkids or ever were a kid you know
there are points along your development
where things change you begin to realize
oh it's not just me who's here you know
at about 2 years old 2 to 3 years old
you begin to realize there's a world
around you that isn't you and isn't
mommy and then you go into puberty and
it's a whole different wake-up call you
know oh geez now what's happening what's
all this then you get out into higher
education or into the working world or
into romance and into a profession and
you're always hopefully waking up to
these next steps and that can be very
good close drama now it can also for the
individual character and how do they
leave what they used to do the problems
inherent in a story like that are your
old habits come back and try to pull you
back in so it's that inertia again and
the problem with that and when I was
studying wonderful classes in the
physics of metaphysics and there was a
lot of physics in there and the teacher
was saying now you just noticed this
when you decide to change and not to do
something anymore so let's say maybe
you've been working as an assistant
director and you say but I really want
to be a line producer and I'm not gonna
do ad anymore she said watch and see
there will usually be three tempting
offers to go back and do first ad work
again and you have to hold strong and
say I don't do that anymore I'm a line
producer
sir unless of course you really need the
money and then you take the job but
there will typically even if it's saying
a friend of mine we were at a party and
this good-looking guy was chatting her
up and the party was over and I said
well Paula what do you think about
George he seemed to be interested in you
and there was a long pause and she said
oh yeah he's good-looking he's smart
he's clever it's funny he's the kind of
mistake I used to make yo yeah yeah so
your character on the wake-up call theme
will be drawn back to the old ways or
just think how hard it is to break a
habit so you're supposed to exercise 30
minutes a day and you do it for a couple
of days and then the third day and the
fourth day it's not quite so much it's
hard to change patterns and this is
something your your character and a
wake-up call has to confront now the
wake-up call is a wonderful beginning
also for a hero and just look at some of
the examples there Arthur with the sword
in the stone
he thought he was just a simple peasant
boy who was you know living with Sir
guy's family and then he finds out he's
the King what or Luke Skywalker doesn't
know who he really is so that discovery
of waking up to who you really are
and it's often said that the world and
our lives would be such a different
place if we would all recognize and be
brave enough to begin living who we
really are
the vast potentials within each of us
the ability particularly as artists to
tap into those higher realms of
creativity and inspiration and bring it
down that's your job by the way as
creative people you are naturally wired
to pick up from the creative
inspirational some would say spiritual
realms and bring that down through your
specific unique persona and then
interpret those ideas and put them out
to the rest of the world receptive to
the higher causative to the lower that's
your job as creative people and
particularly as storytellers so along
that wake-up call theme this kind of
thing can be really well developed in
your story and show how a person's scope
of perception goes from what's kind of
just all about me to you know this is a
pretty good group and we're doing well
here together and then why we're all
here in this gathering is because we
also have a wider perspective on the
global challenges on the world so show
your characters shift from the close to
the further out to the the global and
you'll really inspire us as we were
inspired by Luke Skywalker as we were
inspired or at least awed by the special
effects in matrix okay that was a really
really good wake-up call story where you
think you think you're in reality ah no
oh now I've just started doing work
consulting some in virtual reality and
wow that's pretty amazing and is
offering very effective methodologies
that physiologically affect you even
more than the one to ten 100 screen
ratio thing where it's one foot away
when it's your smartphone it's two feet
away when it's your computer screen five
feet a rather ten feet away if you're
watching a TV from your couch and then
if you're in a theater it could be 50 or
100 feet away and you you experience the
storytelling and the visuals differently
according to where the screen is play
and so as storytellers you know keep
that in mind one of my favorite films
ever was Lawrence of Arabia and when
people started being able to watch
movies on cell phone and went why would
you I mean you're gonna lose half a it's
gonna be just little ants down there
you're not gonna get it so if you're
making a web series you're going to
compose your shots differently than if
you're doing something in 70 millimeter
that just goes without saying and now
virtual reality and I would urge you if
you haven't yet experienced it try to
experience the goggles because it's it's
going to require a different type of
storytelling simply because the way you
can do the the way you can't do cuts and
the way you have to do the the flow of
the visuals did you have a question
that's a good question and I think I'll
be looking more into that but yet the
answer is yes of what we're finding -
now is that a lot of the virtual reality
experiences have built into the system's
a way for the goggles to know where
you're looking so they can then move
important visuals to that spot and
there's a well it's just everyday there
are new developments in the technology
and in this storytelling but yeah it's
much more I think you're right much more
theatrical than it is filmic because you
don't have the the cuts and the in the
same way that you do otherwise but I'm
still exploring it so we'll talk more
about that and certainly if any of you
have some good suggestions on where to
learn more about that - I'd be
interested in hearing because there's a
lot out there but it's it's a developing
art form and it's very exciting okay now
another
another really effective mythic theme is
twins okay having both sides of a
situation or a a conflict so for
instance if you're doing the let's say
the rich-poor gap you've got one and
they don't have to be obviously you know
physically related twins but it's that
whole concept of the the good like in
the dark night was a really good example
of the twins concept at work okay so and
also the movie heat which is with De
Niro and the other guy who's the other
guy in it Pacino thank you so much yes
Pacino and De Niro and it's a twins
story and this can be really effective
to bring out in dialogue and in the
locales where your your characters live
the differences you know one of them
lives in a castle the other lives in a
peasant hut and yet they represent two
sides of a conflict of a story so you
can really use that a lot and what's an
effective thing to in your story arcs is
where you've got let's say what at the
beginning of the story let's see you're
left with ok the beginning of the story
one characters here and the others here
through the course of the story they
cross and take the opposite positions
and that can be really interesting where
the good guy becomes corrupted and the
bad girl becomes enlightened so you can
do a lot with the twins theme and then
also just you know within us we have at
least one other personality more like
lots more probably but the twins theme
can also be internal as well as external
and it gives you a really good
opportunity to raise questions about
climate change or technology or edge
pation and you because dramas conflict
if you get a twins thing in there you've
got a good opportunity for conflict now
also keep in mind I should mention that
you don't necessarily just have one
theme unless it's a short film for a
longer story and certainly if you get
into a TV series you can have your main
theme and then your subplot theme and
then a theme for the romance or once
again if it's a TV series depending on
how long it goes you can work a lot of
themes in under your main theme but
there will be one overarching theme okay
twins is a good one
search for the promised land we've
talked a little bit about that before
and this is usually a much bigger in
scope story because it's about not just
an individual but it's about a group of
people who you know see more at
immigration around the world right now
for various reasons people are being
displaced and they have to go look for
another place to be out of sheer
survival and sometimes you bet for
economic advantage and sometimes just
for adventure
now as often we are reminded America is
a young country and all of us who
weren't here when the Europeans started
coming over are immigrants right so you
know kind of get a sense of perspective
on this down with the immigrants thing
because most of us them have at one
point or another been met and a lot of
times it was just for adventure so the
search for the Promised Land can be a
journey of a group of people for various
reasons and then do they make it do they
not how many of them make it what are
the results and along the way you can
put up lots of barriers and conflicts
and challenges to them so it is a rich
opportunity also it offers
you a lot of opportunity to use symbols
and again think of Mad Max fury road and
the you know the wide-open spaces and
they're headed for what was once a green
and fertile land and when they get there
there's nothing there and that that
symbol of that seer open wasteland is
just no hope no hope and they had to
turn around and go back which is kind of
a twist on the search for the Promised
Land theme it didn't end like most of
them do so in that sense they they
really played with that theme and I
think did a nice job of saying what do
you do if when you get there it ain't
there no more and it's quite dramatic so
you see in a way like because it's like
they have to go back to where they
started right and I feel like Wizard of
Oz is the whole idea that there's no
place like home
so like this weird just tobe in search
for something that really you started
that you know that that's a good
question um right offhand I would say
not exactly because well you although
she was forced into being lost being an
immigrant being a an explorer because of
the tornado okay definitely we're gonna
write this down and think about that
some more thank you and that's a wake-up
call story to particularly for there
were three companions who realized oh
they had it all within them all along
okay another one is war in heaven so a
lot of what's going on behind these
global challenges are battles of ideals
and agendas
and whether it's like in the Cold War
communism versus capitalism whether it's
like the Peloponnesian wars with Sparta
versus Athens two different lifestyles
the Athenians were very it was sort of
like Beverly Hills versus boot camp
yeah because Sparta was all austere and
it's the warrior thing and we're tough
and yeah but it changed the course of
history that war did went on for 23
years and changed everything it's been
likened in military parlance to a battle
between a whale and an elephant because
one of them had a great army in the end
the other had a great Navy and so you
know this war in heaven roamed all over
the place geologically so we're seeing
that somewhat in the politics of today
not just here but around the world where
different people's vision of how the
world should be is on trial and the
battle lines are being drawn no I think
it should be this way and this is how
everybody should act and this is what
should happen well no it should be this
way and this is how everybody should act
and this is how it should happen and
you've got that that dichotomy that
conflict once again your hero rises
above conflict gets up to a position
where they can see concept and that's
where you can begin to make changes yeah
you need people fighting in the trenches
absolutely you need people to register
if they can and go out and vote
whichever way they choose to but we're
going to get changes when we rise above
the conflict and don't get caught up and
trapped in it and can see the concepts
and then start to make changes that way
from that different perspective another
one is the going native now this is kind
of a reverse of the wake-up call but not
really but you've got an individual who
goes into a culture that they are not
familiar with but they eventually become
part of it and so the opportunity for
you when you're talking about stories
that can change the world is this new
person in the situation has to learn
about that culture so you've got a
perfect opportunity think of avatar and
I think why it was so popular is one of
these underlying mythic themes of going
native you know you have Jake who comes
from the military arm of an extraction
capitalism system and he goes into an
interconnectedness where all is won and
we are with nature system and it's
explained to him and shown to him and he
experiences it and as we watch it we
learn so putting your character in a
unique stranger in a strange land
situation and a lot of sci-fi stories
are about this because it's a perfect
setup for showing us a system and
showing us how people can adapt or not
or bring changes in so take a look at
some of the these stories listed there
under a going native and you can see how
you can use this to your advantage in a
story that you want to address let's say
maybe technology so you have somebody
who doesn't know anything about
technology coming into a system and as
its be as they're learning about it as
it's being explained to them they're
going to be able to see more of the
downfall than the people who drunk the
kool-aid or wired the tech or whatever
so you have once again that chance to
have an outside perspective and then
either that person depending on how
you're setting up your story that person
then can be a changed by going native
like Jake was in Avatar or they can go
in and they can change the system
by bringing something new into it yes
I'm sorry I just want to make sure going
native isn't on the handout rates some
being thank you it's not on the one that
you'd have oh okay and certainly if any
of you want to take some of the extra
handouts if you have other people who
might like to have the information do
feel free to do that yeah now one last
thing and then we'll take a little break
the search for the Holy Grail
in a sense that's what you're doing
you're looking for answers that will
solve the problems of the kingdom
the Holy Grail serves the kingdom or
let's say the group the Empire whatever
and in your search for that we are told
that our job is to be like Parsifal and
he was the knight who really wanted to
find the Holy Grail and he wanted to be
a better person than he was and he
wanted to serve and all the knights went
out but along with him went Galahad who
was a very young and innocent Knight and
he was looking for the light and the
purity and he was pure and the third one
was gala hey um Gawain and he was a
party boy and it's like okay adventure
alright do some winch and do some dragon
fighting do some drinking and it's gonna
be a lot of fun oh and if we find the
Holy Grail that's good too so they go
out they have all their adventures
what's interesting to us as storytellers
is at the end of their quest the Grail
does appear now Galahad because he is
pure he gets taken up into the light
Gawain can't even see the light it's
probably got a bad hangover and he's
just what huh I don't get it
Parsifal sees the light of the Grail but
he's still of the earth so he doesn't
get taken up into the light his job is
to be the doorway
and that's our job as artists that's
your job as storytellers is to be the
doorway because a lot of people can't
see the light but they could see you and
you are that that pivot point that door
that once again receptive to the higher
causative to the lower you're at that
point there where you can see it and you
can point it out and you can explain it
to people and then the hope is with the
myth and with our own work then others
will begin to see it too and we should
of course stay humble about that and not
think that we've got the only answer and
the only light but that that is the
mythic position of the storyteller is to
be like parts of all so on that note we
will take a little break for breaks sake
and then we will come back and we will
talk about the arca paths and about
symbolism and then we will have the Q&A
okay thank you all all right so we've
talked about mythic themes and I want to
now tell you something about an
important thing you need to have in your
story and that is mythic statements and
there is a page there in your handouts
for the mythic statements and yes
subtext is important absolutely you
don't want your dialogue on the nose
however there are three times in a story
when you need to have somebody
specifically say what's going on
and those three mythic statements are
the thematic statement what's the story
about the mission statement what's the
hero supposed to do and the lesson
statement what does the heroine hero
learn so the thematic statement the
mission statement and the lesson
statement now you know that you're
supposed to write the beginning of your
story like a hologram of the story
so that we know pretty quickly whether
it's a comedy a drama is it sci-fi how
are we supposed to think about it I
think the best example of that to me is
from the first Star Wars movie and I
mean the first one that came out forget
that other confusing numbering system so
you're sitting there and it's this big
field of stars right and the writing's
going by and there's this little this
the ship you don't how big it is but the
ship comes flying in and it's going go
in and go and you go okay we're in space
alright got that and then the theater
starts to rumble and surround-sound is
shaking the place and from behind you on
the right comes in the prow of a ship
and it's going and it gets bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and it's
going after that little one and right
then you know ah David and Goliath in
space brilliantly done holographic
opening tells you what the story is
about at the very beginning yes I
certainly will and I'll give you some
examples yeah the the three things are
the myth the thematic statement what's
the story about
and that usually comes in the first act
and pretty pretty early on so we know
what the story is about because we all
have seen so much we've read so much we
know so much we're exposed to so much
you need to get us focused right away on
your story the second is the mission
statement what's the hero's supposed to
be doing now that typically will also
come in the first you know it's used
like to use the these strict page number
paradigms that's like page 10 okay when
the hero gets the mission ah now I've
got to go and
do XYZ and then that's that sets it off
on the course and then the the third is
the lesson statement the Epiphany when
the hero learns what they really were
meant to learn and it's some often not
the same as the mission statement it's
something usually internal and it's
something that we are supposed to be
able to apply personally to us as well
the magic statement is the big theme the
mission statement is the goal the
mission and then the lesson statement is
the Epiphany or the lesson that the hero
learns in the course of the story now
whether or not your protagonist once
again wins or not they should still get
the lesson even if they didn't make it
to victory even if they weren't able to
fulfill their mission so the lesson
statement will typically come at the end
of the story however my favorite movie
of all time is Apocalypse Now it's
exceptionally mythic and they mix it all
up and everything happens at the
beginning of the story and we first hear
from captain Willard about what he
learned and he says everybody gets
everything they asked for I asked for a
mission and for my sins
they gave me one and he says it's no
accident that I was the keeper of
Colonel Kurtz's story because to tell
his story is to tell my story so right
there at the very beginnings like whoa
now what's going to happen and then we
get the mission and he he goes to the
the trailer where the general and the
CIA guy in Harrison Ford
are there and he gets his mission and
his mission is to go upriver find
Colonel Kurtz who is acting beyond all
reasonable pale of human responsibility
he's become a god is like it's got to be
over so his mission is terminate the
Colonel's command terminate with extreme
prejudice go take him out
so the thematic statement is given right
after that and the general says there's
a conflict in every heart between the
rational and the irrational and the good
does not always win sometimes the dark
side overcomes what Lincoln called the
better angels of our nature every man
has got his breaking point and that's
your thematic statement you know it's a
battle between light and dark and it
happens in here as well as out there now
on your own I would suggest that you
read the mythic statements from Lord of
the Rings and there on that that page of
the examples if we were showing clips
I'd show the clip but then we'd all be
in tears it's so fabulous
but it's about story and darkness and
once again the mission of the
storytellers it's just brilliant so
that's about themes well let's talk
about characters and character arcs now
there are in the okay you're all
familiar with archetypes we're having
some young mentions up here and
archetypes plenty of them lots of them
you know the orphan the lover the martyr
the mother the king the warrior that
this the that the other okay and that's
all well and good that's great in the
deeper aspects of many spiritual systems
various what's called the paths to
enlightenment
the five calves of enlightenment and
those five paths are the path of the
warrior the path of clergy the path of
the scientist the magician and the lover
and any archetype can be under any of
those paths so you can have a martyr
lover you can have the orphan scientist
etc but these are bigger overreaching
and I call them the ARCA paths and it's
it's a whole lot more I find it more
efficient it's not as unwieldy as all
the different archetypes because it
gives you a clear concise way to craft
your characters to take them through
changes and to have dramatic conflict
between characters now I'm going to
explain to you using the war your ARCA
path and then the conceptual
explanations will apply to all the other
four as well and then you've got
information on your handouts about the
various aspects
what's handy for us as storytellers is
that each of the paths has three levels
and this is just really consistent
throughout most cultures your initiative
systems Freemasonry you've got the
entered apprentice and then you've got
the adept and then the master you've got
grade school middle school high school
okay you've got bachelor's degree
master's degree a PhD steps of three are
pretty typical and another one of those
numbers that shows up a lot so take a
look at the the warrior the steps are
the soldier the warrior and the monarch
what we're interested here in when
you're building your characters is the
effect think of an upside-down pyramid
and the first step is that that lower
step
and think about the soldier or let's
even with the clergy the the novice okay
you don't know much you're just starting
out you're taking orders
you're not thinking for yourself and you
don't have a really big influence on the
world around you you're at this bottom
little level here and that's where you
start building it your rake in the rocks
you're doing the the exercises you're
learning how to use your weapons etc
it's all about learning and it's also
hopefully about being devoted to moving
up so then that's a great opportunity
for you to have your character learn
things and then get promoted if you will
into that next level that middle level
is where most will live and the second
level because not everybody makes it up
to the top level it's more rare but
there's a wider effect on the world
around them so where the soldier level
doesn't have a whole lot of influence
the warrior level does and the warrior
is a leader they're out there in the
vanguard of the charge they're the one
who can assess the battlefield make
decisions right then and there what
should we do there the people on the
frontlines of protests they're the ones
who are strategizing and making all of
the plans for what's going to happen and
this is across the board too with the
other ARCA pass and they know what
they're doing and excite rust me I know
yeah I know what I'm doing I'm trained
I'm a trained professional okay and the
next step up then is more rarefied and
that is the monarch the ruler the the
general the Empress the deity that is
commanding the armies you know a lot of
those in the Egyptian mythology to you
you see that hierarchy and well just
about everywhere so the thing to
remember with that also is they have a
wide range of influ
it's on the world below and around them
and so how would you visualize that in
your stories as simple as having if I
was at the soldier level and you all
were too we might be two separate groups
little companies and then when we're at
the warrior level there'll be more
people and then at the monarch level
you're looking down over the large crowd
so think of it in terms as in terms of
the scope of your blocking of a scene is
it close is it medium is it a wide shot
and the influence that the people have
on those a very good example of a
character on the warrior path who in
doing the rise in the fall has a fall
first it's what we see and that's in
Gladiator because at the beginning of
that story Russell Crowe is a general
and he's probably going to be an emperor
but so he's at the very top right but he
gets captured plummets to the very
bottom and the rest of the story is
about him making his way back up the
levels and that can be really really
effective so wherever you put your
characters at the beginning of the story
are they striving to rise up are they in
level two and real satisfied and they
get tempted down or hit down maybe they
become a refugee they've been a doctor
on the scientist path then and war comes
to their country now there are a refugee
now they're nothing how do they get back
up well in Gladiator Russell Crowe used
his talents and his determination and
the help of some friends that he made
along the way and he does make his way
back up and in his last actions he does
something that is very top level he
makes a personal self sacrifice for the
good of the Republic
the Empire so when you're talking about
character change and growth think about
moving around those levels also each of
the paths has three approaches the
emotional the mental and the synthesized
and I saw this really in action when I
was in a think tank for the army and a
number of the people who were we were
all working on the warrior spirit and
bringing mythology into the military etc
this was during the Clinton
administration's right after the fall of
the wall it was a peace dividend and
everybody was you know wow let's see
what else we can do with the military
because we're not fighting the Cold War
anymore okay well that was nice for a
while but during that time it was
interesting to see which of the Warriors
and these were mostly officers were more
inclined towards emotional and
passionate and idealistic and which were
more inclined towards the the rational
the analytical the strategic and yet
they were all on the warrior path and
which ones were synthesized and those
were typically the the generals and some
of the more you know high-ranking
because that's how you get there is by
being able to synthesize both of those
paths so that's another point of
conflict for you
you've got characters let's say one
who's at the top one who's at the bottom
they're at odds with each other
somebody's on the emotional path someone
else is on the rational path they're at
odds with each other and then how do you
resolve that through the course of your
story
keeping in mind we're talking about
stories that can change the world you
know be sure to give them some of those
speeches some of those positions and
conflicts a wonderful cauldron in which
to put different ingredients and stir it
up and the heat comes and wow you can
get some amazing things
happening so be sure to keep your
conflict going also keeping in mind that
one of the reasons again that we have
these problems is because people have
different agendas whether it's the rich
poor gap whether it's international
crime and all the way to education who
gets educated who doesn't people have
different agendas so you can have those
agendas come out in those three levels
or in the three paths and you know
hopefully get your characters your
protagonists and some of the others to
become synthesized and to get in to say
the the upper boundary between the
second level and that higher level yes
question
[Music]
there's a lot of anti-heroes right our
workers so great okay good question you
have to have a righteous path for the
protagonist because a lot of anti heroes
for instance are in the military a lot
of them are warriors yes that's the
nature of your question yeah I think
especially today that a lot of the most
compelling stories in my opinion where
like you you don't want them to win but
you you do in some sort of way because
become emotionally attached to that so I
guess I'm just trying to understand how
that would be okay an antihero is still
a hero but they're going against the
establishment right they're against the
system that's what makes them anti they
are rebellious and that's where a lot of
your heroes come from are from the
rebellious side the ones who once again
step out or step up from the established
way of doing things
absolutely anti-heroes I think are
really really important and particularly
today because if we do nothing if we do
not rebel in some way against the status
quo against what's happening we're not
going to change anything so we probably
need more anti-heroes what's interesting
and some of us were discussing this
fairly recently and somebody said well
the antihero often does the right thing
without meaning to and then what happens
to them when all of a sudden they've
done the right thing and they've spent
their whole time trying to be the
resistor to be the rebel you what what
so you can give them a real emotional
quandary when that happens
and once again keeping in mind that
principle of even if it doesn't happen
to the protagonist or the antagonist we
need to know what could happen so we're
always wanting to know what's that goal
what would heaven look like what would
winning be and your antihero can be I
think really effective in pointing out
the flaws of a system they have they
have carte blanche to do that that's
their job as the antihero is to say what
are you people thinking you have any
idea what you're doing so I they can be
very very effective in bringing out the
the theme and the lessons in a story and
you're right they're usually the most
interesting ones one of my favorite
anti-heroes is in an old film from
walter hill and it's called Streets of
Fire Diane Lane is in it and it came out
I think in 82 maybe it's a rock and roll
fable Willem Dafoe Diane Lane it's
fabulous we watch it like twice a year
and we know all the lines and it's oh
it's so much fun Streets of Fire check
it out and Michael Perret is the
antihero in that he's got this wonderful
line where he says yeah something like
I'm not a hero I'm the kind of guy that
other guys stand to do jobs like this
perfect antihero so the thing to also
keep in mind with your ARCA pass is the
key word and their mission and once
again this is on your handouts but I'll
just go through the one for the Warriors
because I think it's so important once
again if we're working on doing stories
that can change the world
the Warriors job and this has gotten so
distorted lately as it does cyclically
throughout history but the Warriors
mission is to protect and defend the
weak and the innocent not the stupid and
the lazy but to protect and defend the
weak and the innocent and also to
promote the good the true and the
beautiful go out there and fight for it
and then also promote it and to reclaim
the warrior path into its ideal valiant
honorable
core would be something wonderful to see
and we certainly need it and certainly a
lot of people who are officially in the
armed services are very idealistic and
they are trying to do these things and
they're often up against a corrupt
system and you know see more at reality
and of course lots of movies so as you
go through these other paths do note
that your characters you want them to be
really identifying with the mission so
also key words the key word for the
warrior is purpose they've got a goal
got a mission and they have to stay on
purpose the clergy path is all about
putting yourself apart from matter
it's about disengaging from the material
world and the key word there is purity
and it's doing the fasts it's going and
living in a cave in Hamas for a month at
a time and having cold rice and yak
butter okay it's austerities right it's
the sacrifices now the clergy path like
every path there's a spectrum and it can
go bad and part of the downside of the
clergy path is you can get into a lot of
self sacrifice and self scourging and
then deciding everybody else should be
surged also and if you're not living up
to my ideal within maybe you shouldn't
be living like say all the past can go
bad but the clergy path has a tendency
to get well as the Monty Python says
nobody expects the Spanish Inquisition
but there it is so you got to watch that
the scientists path I find really
interesting because the top level of the
scientist path from student curious
wants to know everything scientist very
adept at what they're do
they're coding they're exploring the
seas they're breaking down the genomes
but the top level of the scientist path
is the philosopher because you're taking
that innate curiosity and that tendency
to look for patterns and to look for
cause and effect and to test it out and
just think of some of the wonderful
books that are written by or just
watched Neil deGrasse Tyson right he's a
philosopher and a lot of those advanced
scientists are they become interested in
consciousness the cosmos is their
intelligence elsewhere the big questions
and the scientists path is about process
if you're writing code and you don't
have absolutely every comma and every
quotation mark in the right place it's
not gonna work the process must be exact
and so also when I teach actors it's
like okay if you if you're on a
scientist path you need everything to be
very neat and all lined up and the
process is really important and so they
act differently
and you can if you're doing novels get
more into that but certainly your
characters can be given some dialogue
and direction that will help in that
portrayal the magician
once again you're all magicians because
you are storytellers the definition of a
magician is someone who sees patterns
that others cannot see and creates
patterns where they did not exist sees
patterns others cannot see creates
patterns where they did not exist that's
a magician by the very act of writing
you are creating patterns that were not
there now you may be following old
patterns like a mythic theme and using
our capaz de Bie unique you know unless
you're a hack writer or you're hired to
be hackish for this project
okay but it's always going to be coming
through your unique personality and you
know if you've taken any writing courses
where you're given an assignment you
know write about your first pet
everybody's stories different even if
everybody had a calico cat the stories
are going to be different because it's
coming through you so you're creating
patterns that did not exist before and
that's your job and the key word for the
magician is performance because
typically if someone's a magician it's
they're very open and wide and
flamboyant and showy and they'll wear
you no capes and exotic jewelry and
maybe have oh wait a minute Harry Potter
you can learn a lot about magicians just
from reading and watching those movies
but it's all about the performance for
magicians and their goal is to get
control of the scene and unseen forces
then the fifth of these paths is the
lubber path I find this one interesting
of course the key word is passion what
else would it be right at the first
level you've got the admirer or the fan
and they are alone your character wants
to be in love they yearn to be in love
but they're alone and that drive drives
in that yearning drives them through the
story so that first level is all about
desiring wanting the dark side of that
stalkers okay it sits on the lover path
but it's that lower level dark side at
the second level on the lover path
you've got relationships so first you've
got a singleton then you've got
relationships whether it's two people or
you've got a polyamorous situation or a
menage tois whatever but there is
relationship at the higher level again
though
you've got more solitary of a position
that's where you find because remember
this is the monarch level the High
Priestess level the philosopher that's
where you'll find your goddesses and
gods of compassion like the Queen Isis
of the Egyptian pantheon the Virgin Mary
Quan Yin in Anna Cara doin you know just
look at the mother goddesses they are
above they may have consorts but it's
not about them in relationship with an
equal it's about them in relationship
with all of those whose lives they
encompass an influence so in the lover
path you go from a singleton to in a
relationship to a person alone but
influencing and collecting within their
area of influence many many many other
people and once again think of these
five paths the three levels and the
three approaches and realize those are
all opportunities for dramatic conflict
and I often find that using the good old
fashioned three by five cards can be
really helpful and I know the the latest
version of final draft also has the
cards breakdown program which can be
very effective too depending on whether
you'd like to handle cards or watch it
on a screen but think of the conflicts
that you can build just by the very
nature of the characters that you are
crafting and that those conflicts are
wonderful opportunities again to get out
your message about one of the global
challenges or some other problem that
you see and then what solutions might be
found now when it comes to symbolism
we're talking about a visual medium here
and there are three levels of simile
some one is the emotional level personal
see it's another set of threes and the
next level is situational and then
conceptual so once again we're going
from close in to further out to the
highest observer level and you'll see
there a a list of movies and particulars
for each of these just using avatar
again at the emotional level for the
symbolism you've got Jake in the
wheelchair
he's immobilized to an extent and that
symbol of the wheelchair also tells us
about his psychological state he's not a
whole person he is disabled emotionally
because of losses and whether it's the
you know the loss of his brother the
loss of his own mobility self-confidence
so it's an excellent symbol for that
emotional personal level then at the
situational level you've got an avatar
again you have the community of the Navi
versus the community of the extraction
capitalists who are there to rape the
planet and the the machines and the
tools versus nature and that situation
of nature versus man-made coming
together is the inherent conflict that
situational conflict and you see that
with the the helicopters and the flying
dragon creatures okay they are one is
symbolic of nature the other is symbolic
of technology it's real obvious it's
real effective and then at the
conceptual level
really nicely done with the
cinematography and the art direction I
think was the the trees where we we've
been seeing that the family trees the
village trees but there towards the end
we see how deep the connection with the
trees goes and how complex is the
interconnectedness and it's that
interconnectedness of all life and
ultimately many would say that's what
we're trying to realize in our own
wake-up calls that's one of the concepts
that's going to help us address any of
these global challenges they're global
because they affect everybody because
we're all interconnected so the
solutions also have to be global because
we're all interconnected and I think
that is one of the biggest challenges in
the challenges is how do you get
everybody to go along with it you've got
ten people and nine of them say hey
that's a great idea let's do that but
the tenth person is the one who holds
the bank account guess what's gonna
happen what that tenth the person wants
to have happen until you can either have
a revolution or a devolution it all
falls apart or our favorite approach
evolution so getting up to that that
sense of interconnectedness and once
again remember that's what a hero does
they stand up above the crowd and they
see things other people did not see
patterns they become a magician they
create patterns they influence more
people around them and they bring about
hopefully very very positive changes so
think about these three levels of the
emotions there's another movie I would
suggest you to see if you have not and
even if you have watch it for these
symbolism and that's Bertolucci's film
be conformist
it's brilliant bear Lucchese brilliant
can't go wrong there but in the
conformist the symbolism is so
exquisitely used on all levels and
you'll see examples there in the handout
but if you can get the conformist on the
DVD there is a wonderful special
features section it might be available
also on the on streaming but it goes
into the symbolism there's a really good
featurette about Bertolucci's symbolism
and it's just brilliantly brilliantly
done and as writers and filmmakers it
can be very inspirational so we've
covered now the need for heroism and
that hopefully you're all going to be
writing wonderful heroes for us how to
use mythic themes and we've discussed
some of them that can be particularly
relevant to this type of storytelling
that has a message and I do this and I
suggest you as well could do this is
just go through those 15 challenges and
say well what mythic theme do I think
could fit under this one real well that
will give you once more and more
facility of working with the mythic
themes and recognizing patterns and
starting to use them we talked about the
mythic statements that every story needs
the thematic statement the mission
statement and the lesson statement and
then we took a look at our capaz de stew
life in styles of interacting with life
the warrior path the clergy path the
path of the scientist of the magician
and the lover and how each of those has
three levels and three approaches and
how you can use those four story arcs
and character arcs and internal and
external conflict and then symbolism the
three levels there of the emotional the
situational and the conceptual
and then how you can use those once
again to reveal the problems that you're
trying to address and show us possible
solutions so what we'll do now is have
question-and-answer time and anybody
have a question in particular yes so
going back to your Holy Grail example so
parts of all warrior of the younger
innocent ones among and then lover or
drunkard give this man and a batsman
right just just because I wanted to
connect it to that story so that's
basically person who ascends person
holds the door person who's kind of in
the shadow aspect of lover loving
alcohol too much right yeah well done
yeah yeah Galahad is on the path of the
clergy
he's the innocent purity parse the ball
is the warrior has a purpose and yeah
Gawain's path of the lover bit of the
dark side on that passion but seriously
you got to have some fun you're on a
mission looking for the Grail things
aren't always fun but yeah where it very
well assess other comments questions yes
and to Patricia Clarkson and and so I
was just wondering aside from the
rich-poor gap
just about a person a widow and she goes
to a town to open up a bookshop and she
changes this is kind of like the town's
very curious about this one child she's
older she has two books that maybe I
think she might have movie better and so
the lady Patricia Clarkson is sort of
the head of the Arts Council wealthy
woman very charming quite socially sort
of skilled and getting people to do her
bidding and she doesn't want this woman
there and it's a fascinating look aside
from the rich-poor gap I'm just sort of
somebody who wants to live out their
passion versus somebody else who's been
Gary established in the town and how
that shakes up the apple cart
I was just wondering aside from to
Bridgeport gap whatever their themes and
I really
yeah I have not seen the bookshop yeah I
haven't seen that it might be you might
have a bit of a stealing fire from
heaven there if the woman who comes in
and is opening the bookshop is bringing
like Lolita new ideas opening literary
concepts bringing in gee maybe we got to
look beyond our own little town borders
so there could be an education and
learning is often on the stealing fire
from heaven path because look at the
first thing the first thing that
oppressive regimes do is what burn the
books and kill the intellectuals so
Harden and the journalists that's right
anybody who can think we cannot allow so
there might be some of that in there as
well and maybe not on the vicious scale
of MMD's murders military dictatorships
but it sounds like that might be one of
them yeah and I've put it down to check
it out thank you other comments
questions yes oh I'm sorry
let's because yep yes sir go ahead well
okay well what is the coming-of-age
hero's journey would it be like if the
he those done like a warrior
those two explores that new world it's
it sounds like it it sounds also like
you've got some wake-up call theme in
there and also a going native theme
because it's an individual going into
another society oh yeah and learning
about some about some group that's very
very different from him just look at
like Dances with Wolves yeah okay
somebody from a different culture
totally going into another one and then
we learn more about that culture that
they go into
so that just right offhand sounds like
something you might look into as far as
a lining border of the mythic theme that
way good luck with that doh see it's a
the nice thing about sci-fi and fantasy
is by their very nature they give us the
opportunity to inspect our reality and
get a different perspective on it good
luck that but I can't believe that
humans are the bad people yeah really
so someone else had another question oh
yes look she was first and then we'll
come to you oh okay quick question do
you think there are stories that instead
of healthy harm mmm good question are
there stories that harm rather than help
addressing these issues global issue
yeah and to me those would be the ones
where people get away with bad stuff and
there are no consequences and the not
just for them because sometimes that's
okay
if we know that somewhere down the line
they're going to get theirs but where
it's just
there's no redemption even offered or no
hope and hope is squash now what would
some of those be
you might ask and now this is just
personal I you know I appreciate that a
lot of people like him I just can't do
the horror movies and I can't do the
horror books I was reading it was one of
the books about alien abduction quit
least drivers book communion I think it
was about alien abductions years ago and
actually I was going to go to a party
and meet him and I thought god traffic
good idea to read the book right well I
had to read it in the daytime at night I
had to put it in the freezer so I could
even sleep it was that disturbing so I
think some of the some of the stories
that don't offer any hope of redemption
or change can be deleterious and they're
often the stories that are telling
telling us just shut up this is the way
things are
you can't protest there's no point in
standing up there's no point in thinking
it could be different this is the way it
is this is the way it's always been
hush up be quiet sit down he just gets
everything he wants yeah that guy died
and then we'll just still make all this
money and then I left that phone being
like what am I supposed to feel now you
know that you should be cut through in
the world to get what you want
Lolita make sure of the question or just
generally in terms of that character
what did he really
Biggi I don't think he learned much but
he was a protagonist right he was he was
he was a very flawed man yeah but then I
guess so then my question is going back
to what she was saying that is like what
if but I think Lolita was so successful
because it was crafted such that we
learned something yeah that we can make
just based off of beautiful prose yeah
yeah minute these days aren't yet like
going around it kind of had one new
question in the same the same thing
again where the work of HP Lovecraft oh
yes you know mythologically base but
it's you've read plenty of it it seems
that he always goes through like super
pains to make the protagonist seem super
super normal and competent and then
slowly you know it there's forces
outside they're just kind of overwhelmed
and then sometimes they make it out
alive sometimes they make you know
scarred but it that's one of the I love
his work personally and that Holden
mythology the mythos has kind of grew up
around it but I was kind of wondering
the same thing where I don't know it it
eats that format as much as I like that
style would
be particularly useful for writing
stories that help change the world and
these particular goals I was kind of
wondering you could because at the end
it's kind of the same thing well what do
you do there's a giant meatball that's
just gonna like eat up the whole
universe there's these catching a glitch
so part of one of his servants which
aren't you insane
but yeah Lovecraft is a good example for
can we find any sense of redemption in
his characters his stories and it's kind
of hard at times like with is it Matthew
McCormack who wrote No Country for Old
Men
yeah his stories are bleak dark Oh once
again can you the question is can you
write that kind of a story and have it
address any of these issues yes you can
I think it's probably more difficult but
if part of what those characters are
going through and up against are these
problems and even if it seems like
futility let's say transnational
organized crime and boy had just look
into that a little bit and I just it
blew my hair back to find out how much
was going on and and but did you know
there's a Mafia force and yeah yeah yeah
look up the sand mafia it's really
interesting yeah so if you if you show
us in one of those dark bleak stories a
situation and think of okay what would
be a good symbol for that situation and
maybe let's just say you're using sand
mafia we're making this up as we go
along maybe somebody is a an
investigative journalist investigating
the sand mafias and comes to a place
where people are just being buried by
the sand anybody who's trying to protest
is just buried by it and cover it up by
it that could be a situational symbol
that you could use so you can work that
in without getting preachy jump off into
another concept here or let's say it's
part of the the alphabet of story it's
the for ease and think of a pie chart
and what is the percentage in your story
if you were drawing the pie chart of
your story how much of it is
entertainment how much of it is
education letting people know something
how much of it is enlightenment bringing
new perspectives and aspiration and
uplifting and how much of it is just
pure expression this is what I want to
do and you know take a look at maybe
your favorite five movies and draw the
pie chart and make sure that one of them
is is something where the director is
very indulgent and it's all about them
and you can tell it's all up there on
the screen y'all are nodding it's like
we've all seen those movies yes and
sometimes and it's perfectly fine it's
95% entertainment and maybe you know 2%
education and 3% enlightenment some of
the transformer films there's a little
bit of message in there but mostly it's
just entertainment and that's okay but
for the type of stories that could
change the world you're going to want to
have a little bit for education and
enlightenment and always you want some
of that to be your personal expression
so that it's coming through you that
we're getting this story and also you
have to make it entertaining or nobody's
gonna watch so it's a it's a flexible
pie chart but but play with that a bit
it can become very enlightening to
yourself as a writer to see what you're
doing and you had a question or comment
is the for ease yeah entertainment
education enlightenment and expression
yes sue I have done a lot of reading on
archetypes themselves and I just wanted
to kind of get your thoughts on
sometimes I have really tough times
choosing a net happiness and I'm just
wondering if at times
the way that I should be looking at
these archetypes I thought the
antagonist is the shadow side of
whatever hero archetype I chose it so
like that's just playing out it's almost
like I'm making the story of like an
internal like I just I wanted to hear
your thoughts on that like finding the
antagonist to be the shouts ID of the
hero yes and that's a that's a very good
point we do want in our antagonists some
equality of function and ability against
the protagonist otherwise you've got
Bambi versus Godzilla and that story
doesn't last very long so yes they can
be speaking of the archetypes or let's
say the arc paths you can have them both
at the scientists the middle level of
the scientist path and one of them's on
the dark and ones on the light so you
got that you could put one of them in
the middle the scientist path and the
other one is a magician still in the
middle path and so they go up against
each other because one is all about
process the other is all about
performance they have different goals
and yet they're at the same level now
choosing the antagonist is really a
tricky thing I deal with it quite a bit
in well a lot in the power of the dark
side book but it's one of the most
challenging aspects of making good
writing is having appropriate
antagonists and also keep in mind though
the antagonist as a character is only
part of it because there's also the
internal problem the situational problem
the societal the global the nature but
yeah that other individual that you're
putting your protagonist up against can
be you can effectively use archetypes by
having them on different aspects of the
same level
in different paths or let's say ones on
the mental side of an of a path and the
others on the emotional side and so
there'll be conflict there but yeah that
sense of balance because once again if
it's you don't put a light weight in the
ring with a heavy weight I mean that's
just like well yeah duh Pamela but I
think at times we forget that and we
make one of them more powerful or more
weak than the other and then there's no
contest and we we'd love to have a world
where it isn't all about drama but we're
still in the world that's full of drama
and conflict so we still have to deal
with that but yeah good question yeah
yes that's interesting you know that's
that's interesting the duty versus
desire theme typically I tend to think
of it as within one person but you I
think what you're saying is you've drawn
it such that the mom is about duty and
the girl is about desire and so you've
got the duty versus desire theme playing
out in two individuals although they're
very close and they are I was mentioning
like having the conflict be like in that
same area that antagonists and
protagonists are almost the same person
right because it's like that's what
you're saying of duty versus desire
mm-hmm yeah that's interesting thank you
somebody should take a note of that Oh
shall we go ahead and have the drawing
because some of you may need to leave
does everyone have their drawing slip in
the yellow bag okay
so let's see here
yes the drumroll it's probably all right
genell's Jeanette oh well all right then
and you have your choice of either of
the books there and other ones are of
course available should anyone else want
to want to purchase one and everything
is available online as well oh and if
once again if you are in the getting on
the mailing list for the the newsletter
I'm also open to suggestions for topics
to cover so if you see something you
think would be something that would that
would be well-served by having a
mythological approach to it you know
please feel free to send in newsletter
article ideas I'd be happy to hear from
you forecast even unintentional I guess
it's not really romantic theme music
about the arrangement but I'm just
wondering if you could talk about just
maybe what in just that the writer is
sort of the forecaster and the criticism
they get
eventually public finds out they were
right okay what I think what you're
describing there is the ARCA path of the
magician because remember the definition
of the magician is one who sees patterns
that others do not see and that's what
futurists are that's what those writers
who who foresee what the next step is
going to be if we keep going down this
path or if you put these things together
this is likely to happen so it's very
much of a magician arca path position
and then going back once again to
Newton's law of inertia when you put new
ideas out there the first thing you get
is what resistance that's it yeah as the
board would say it resistance is futile
or as they say in Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy if you haven't read the book
it's fabulous
so yeah the the future the person who
sees the future is typically not
believed because here again other people
can't see it
so they think you're crazy or you're
just intuitively woowoo but that's not
reality that's fantasy oh it's a good
story but that could never happen so
that's that's where I would classify
them now as for a particular theme it
could also be under the stealing fire
from heaven because you're bringing
something that the group doesn't have
and some people there resist it and you
could also probably have a bit of
wake-up call in there because somebody
is actually doing the wake-up call and
we are the people who need to be
awakened but also Pluto's cave just the
whole idea like they got out of the cave
and they're like come on like be free
and they're fighting it rights form
resists change that's just the nature of
reality and yeah anybody that's trying
to prod
out of our comfortable spaces and we
fear change it's a survival mechanism
we're supposed to fear change it can
kill you
but you're not going to progress unless
you make some changes and those who see
it first are often feared I would say
also because if that were true then we
might have to change and what would that
be like so yeah lonely at the top and
lonely at the front but that's that's
your job as storytellers is to do that
well thank you all so much
I really look learned a lot thank you
and thanks so much to film courage for
all that you do it's wonderful work and
best of luck to all of you and not to
keep you posted on what you're working
on I'd like to hear how you're applying
these wonderful old classical mythic
story tools to what you're doing and
which problems are you addressing so
please do it I'd be interested in
knowing how it all goes
you're very welcome I enjoyed it early
thanks yes yeah I do story consultation
and also a personal myth consultation
helping people figure out what their
path is what what's their arca path and
how best to use it